سترى أنه يأتي من خلال الجزء العلوي من
الشاشة هناك ، ثم تنتقل
الكاميرا لتتبعه ، تم تصوير هذا
الفيديو الحكومي الأمريكي الذي تم رفع السرية عنه حديثًا لـ
UAP أو ظاهرة شاذة مجهولة الهوية
بواسطة طائرة بدون طيار عسكرية في
الشرق الأوسط في
عام 2022.  تُعرف باسم UFOs ،
وهي في الأساس جميع البيانات التي
ربطناها بهذا الحدث منذ
بضع سنوات ، وهي حالة لم يتم حلها ، وما
زلنا ندرس مدير
مكتب حل شذوذ المجال الجديد في البنتاغون ، حيث شارك aaro
الفيديو خلال الولايات المتحدة.  تستمع لجنة مجلس الشيوخ إلى
كيف أن العدادات التي لا يزال يتعين
حلها ، مجرد تحديث من
تقريرك العام لشهر يناير حيث كان 366
أو كان هناك حوالي 150
بالونات وحوالي عشرين كانت طائرات بدون طيار
نتتبعها في إجمالي 650
حالة ،
شكرًا لك